Mark Twain was famous for saying
everyone complains about the weather but
no one ever does anything about it well
obviously to control the weather you'd
have to have superpowers
a simple thunderstorm has more energy
than a hydrogen bomb so to control the
weather is very difficult to see I ain't
tried it during the Vietnam War they
tried to seed the clouds with crystals
iodide crystals that form nuclei to form
rain clouds to stimulate a monsoon
season the CIA did not like the Viet
Cong and the Viet Cong will operate in
the jungles so why not stop them in
their tracks by seeding the clouds and
creating an artificial monsoon well that
was a failure and it's very humbling
knowing that many countries have tried
to control the weather
none of these Harebrained Schemes have
actually worked however now that we have
global warming some people are saying
that we really should think about
altering the weather itself there is a
doomsday plan proposed by a Nobel
laureate and that is that if the
greenhouse effect spirals out of control
we should put rockets to shoot
pollutants into the atmosphere to
reflect sunlight back into outer space
that would be a doomsday mechanism to
control the weather but weather control
is really for a type one civilization
minimum hundred years into the future